bref
les petits boulots mais je compte
que
j'étais bébé que ma mère a tenu une
pêche aux canards qu'elle
j'étais destinée
je vous fais ce que ce n'est pas deux
fois
[Musique]
- c'est kelly je suis fort et tu foraine
depuis que je suis est là actuellement
menés sur glace blanche avec mon mari
qui est lui pas forains du tout voilà je
mets sur les actes que j'ai rencontré et
rencontre aussi son milieu c'est lui qui
m'a plu je suis encore d'attaqué depuis
tous trois maires et du coup vous êtes
armés il sait comment outil de choix
sans le christ au rituel thibault lui
hélas
pas comme ça jamal jeux pour les enfants
jusqu'à électrique c'est comme une
petite autoroute qui - ça fait quand
même huit en fait et moi j'ai un demi
ton général qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est
ça les toits du coup tu t'occupes moi je
suis de travail stationnaire
c'est quoi qu'on se parle beaucoup moins
par exemple ce qu'on voit c'est quand on
démonte le manège est comparé dans la
prochaine destination il faut acheminer
la pyrale caravane il faut amener le
manège le met en place le monter le
démonter l'entretenir le réparer
l'améliorer ça prend du temps de
démonter un manège certains quartiers de
manège de nous faire un portrait assez
gros et claude balland et pour monter et
une demi journée pour démonter et ça
c'est tous les combien
sur l'étang ça dépend des défaites qui
dure que le week-end ya les partisans
quinze jours à des faits divers un mois
et des fêtes comme ici les emplacements
en isolé on reste trois mois moment et
comment ça se choisissent a en fait
c'est selon vous les villes que vous
voulez selon les emplacements ya en fait
selon la tournée qu'on achète ou alors
après c'est il ya beaucoup de fêtes moi
qu'il me viennent de mon père comme mon
père m'a légué mon père m'a transmis son
nom mais mois plus tard je ferais pareil
avec mes enfants
[Musique]
on va papa
suggérer qu'une barbe à papa
j'aurai ma boutique à chez moi
ensuite
l'école nous on change que 4,5 fois
d'emplacement donc les petits vont ils
vont 3 84 écoles différentes pas mon
fils là 17 de moyenne donc il n'est pas
perturbé du tout par rapport à l'école
on va où les du coup à la fête foraine
audi a6 les anciens partis bout d'un
jour le monde s'est tu sais que je
change de voix c'est pas ma voix voilà
je te parle normale et quand je vais
parler prenez place j'ai vous attends je
prends une autre voie j'ai un klaxon sur
manège
est ça qui se consomme certes il ya des
gens qui se met le manège arruda il
monte sur la piste pour prendre en photo
les enfants qui longtemps regardent ils
montent sur la piste et le train geek
sûr on y apprend on à travers le jeu
est gratuite ce soir c'était une blague
vous voilà on est passé tout le monde a
été comme ça à faire des petites
polémiques
a écrit plus grands bons derniers l'an
dernier sur ce mardi
moi je suis totalement épanoui dans ma
vie de femme dans la vie tu m'as mis
dans mon travail dans tout j'ai vraiment
trouvé ma voie le bonheur et c'est ce
choix d'être
pierre st-amand nous chez ma mère si et
il ya énormément de clichés sur les gens
du voyage pour un gitan
et tout ce qui s'ensuit mais c'est le
monde de l'art c'est fait et c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut faire découvrir
alors que vous faire un musée sourire
moi c'est le but de raconter
[Rires]
[Musique]